hey guys we are back with a brand new
day and a brand new slew of news stories
and it's if you hit that subscribe
button you won't miss a single news
story but for now here's what happened
today if you're still hunting the
Bolivian cartel in Ghost Recon wildlands
we've got some goodies the new title 5
update is out and it makes some big
changes the biggest change to the
open-world dad joke simulator is the
inclusion of the new tier 1 difficulty
mode not only does it make the game more
difficult it also changes up the
leveling system you'll now start at
level 50 and work your way down to level
1 by earning tier points instead of XP
tier 1 mode can be enabled from the menu
after reaching level 30 there's also
your classic bug fixes in this patch and
a new HUD indicator that lets you know
why you've been detected you can check
out the full list of changes in a story
on GameSpot in stories that make me feel
bad for Dan who actually dropped money
on buying until dawn just last month
until dawn is one of the games that's
included in next month's PlayStation
Plus bundle but don't cry for me because
there's a bunch of others as well
seriously this next month is what I
would call a doozy if I was the kind of
person who used the word doozy I got to
stop letting Jess write me these things
on ps4 you'll get until dawn which is
fantastic by the way Telltale's Game of
Thrones series and don't die mr. robot
which is also available on Vita via
cross-buy if you're still hugging your
fat ps3 like I find myself doing on the
odd Friday night you'll be able to get
your paws on Darkstalkers resurrection
which is actually a collection of two
different games from the dark stalkers
fighting game series night warriors
Darkstalkers revenge and Darkstalkers 3
if all that sounds pretty intense
not to worry ps3 earners you're also
getting Tokyo jungle that game where you
play as a Pomeranian among other animals
in a post-apocalyptic version of Tokyo
theater owners can also pick up indie
platformer element 4l or elemental it's
got a 4 in there but it doesn't stop
there a booster pack for Orcs Must Die
Unchained is available for PlayStation
Plus subscribers and you can pick up the
upcoming multiplayer play link game
that's you feel free until October 24
finally by aware of taste that something
is happening with Dragon Age
like Western like what alright easy
while appearing on the 1099 podcast
series creative director Mike Laidlaw
confirmed that the Dragon Age team is
currently hiring a lot of people that
sounds like development it's ramping up
he also went on to say quote I am the
creative director for the Dragon Age
franchise and I haven't fired me yet oh
boy elsewhere on the podcast Laidlaw
taste that Bioware
is working on other things but quote
unfortunately I can't talk about them
until they're realized I am pretty
excited about a few of them things
continue apace let us know what you want
from a new Dragon Age in those comments
below
that's GameSpot news for today and if
you've made it this far why not grab the
game for now app on iOS and Android so
you can get the top 10 news stories from
the day delivered right to your phone
thanks so much for joining us once again
let us know all your thoughts and
feelings in that comment box where you
will find us and we will see you same
time tomorrow